ald
[Silence]
We are
continuing our reading of a
chapter in the
book
for this class is
on
however this portion of the book
which we initially did not do when we
began the
series this portion is very important
and it is more complete and more
comprehensive
from this is where the origin of many of
these things come from going all the
way back
to
in the thir Century
authored a book other than his Sunan
known
as which in which he gathers all of the
narrations discussing the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam descriptions
and anything having to do with him
so the reason why we are reading this
from is because it's more
comprehensive and then inshallah we will
continue on in Z all of our classes in
z have not been exclusively taken
from there are things which we have
discussed and added from other books as
well as we mentioned before
Z is very comprehensive but
nonetheless he wrote the book from
memory and so there are some
additional things which he didn't
mention either because he didn't think
of them at the time of writing the book
or because he was he left them out
for whatever
purpose
and the prophet s alai wasam spent many
of his
nights along with his
wives
in a state of
hunger this was due to
Poverty due to the fact that they were
in Medina they had just migrated they
were just getting their own footing
started also the issue
of uhu they were under siege a lot a lot
of times they were out in battle and
so forth and these things demand a lot
of
resources so the beginning days in
Medina were very very
difficult and the prophet
s. his mattress that he would lay
on was usually made from a hide usually
it would either
be sheep hide or goat
hide
and the stuffing of the mattress is
leaf and leaf is when you chip the bark
off of a palm tree there's this kind of
it's almost shredded newspaper
inside right this spongy this here is
called leaf so what is between the bark
and the actual Wood of the palm tree
that leaf they would scrape that out
because it has some fluff to it and they
would stuff their mattresses with that
usually those mattresses were not
considered very comfortable obviously
these
are these are the traits of a person who
whom his mattress is very very
Thrifty very very
very
this is not something that is a trade
of the people of wealth people of wealth
they would either
use hair or they would
use cotton or any of the things that we
stuff our mattresses with today but his
was made of leather
and it was stuffed with
[Silence]
Leaf he says that the prophet s. wasam
had very few
possessions basically any POS possession
of his that he had had a purpose and he
only had exactly the amount of things
that he needed in order to get through
his day and
night so his possessions were very few
and Allah subhanahu waala had given him
the keys to opening the Treasures of the
entirety of the Earth but the prophet
sallallah alai wasam
chose to
not be privy to those riches and that he
chose the Hereafter over this
D
[Silence]
says
he mentions here that the prophet
sallallah alai wasam was in constant
remembrance of
Allah and was in constant deep thought
was very
meditative and most of the
time
when you know if there was something
funny or something he would
smile rarely he would smile wide
enough at times that
his teeth would show his rear teeth
would show however most of the time
it was just a
smile and he was very fond of
perfumes and he very much
disliked smells that were foul and
offensive and he used to
play and joke on occasion but
never with that which is inaccurate
or untrue
Never by saying something that is untrue
he would only say that which is true and
that which is appropriate even in his
jokes and a person who comes to him with
an excuse he would accept the excuse
this is an impressive
trait that a person accept the excuse of
a person who
is apologizing
or trying to excuse themselves a lot of
times people's excuses are not very
valid a lot of times people's excuses
are very pathetic
however Allah subhanahu waala tells
[Silence]
him
a lot of times when people give excuses
for their foul actions or their behavior
or their inaction or their
complacency their excuses are not
valid however the prophet sallallah
wasam would not bicker with people and
he would not hold
them and try to challenge their
excuses in most
cases rather he would accept their
excuse in hopes that they would revisit
their action and better
[Silence]
themselves
for
[Silence]
was
for
Allah subhanahu waala described the
prophet s.
wasam in the ninth chapter of the Quran
verse number
128 he says that which translates to
addressing the
Companions and the people ofr
specifically indeed an exalted messenger
has come to you all from your from
amongst your own selves
any type of difficulty is is hard upon
him to see you go
through meaning that he will avoid and
do everything in his
power to prevent any difficulty or
hardship upon his
umah Allah subhana describes him as well
as he is in constant
constantly
striving to obtain the best for you
all and for the Believers he
is very forgiving and
[Silence]
merciful
Allah subhanahu wa taala tells tell us
in verse Number
103 of the nth
chapter he says subhanahu waala that
which translates to and pray for them
meaning the
Believers Allah subhanahu wa taala says
at the beginning of this verse
instructing his messenger Muhammad s.
wasam take what they bring you of their
zakah and of their charity that they
give this will act as an experation and
a purification for
them
and pray for them indeed your prayer
is a Tranquility that will descend upon
[Silence]
them
for
[Silence]
and we tells us that often
times when the prophet
Sall wish to admonish someone for doing
something someone who who does something
or or admonish people for not doing
something that they should have been
doing usually this was very indirect he
would
indirectly
admonish how would he indirectly
admonish he would speak to the group
intending a particular person or a
particular action so if there's a group
instead of pointing out the
person and admonishing the person
rebuking the person
publicly he would
admonish in a generalized
way
indirectly and say something along the
lines what is with such and such people
who do such and such or people who do
not do such and such Etc there are many
examples of
this
[Silence]
and now what we hear describ the prophet
s. saying that he
would be
constantly commanding and reminding
people to be gentle
gentleness is
the the
norm harshness is the exception is there
a place for harshness yes there's a
place for harshness but harshness is the
exception it is the exception to the
rule the
norm is
gentleness and he would encourage people
to be gentle amongst one another and he
would discourage people
likewise from harshness to not be
harsh and he would constantly encourage
people to forgive to Pardon one
another this issue
of gentle
it doesn't just
mean
gentleness with other people doesn't
just mean gentle with certain people in
general anytime we deal with another
person gentleness is the rule harshness
is the exception to the rule and the you
know
abnormal kind of
situation
also
gentleness with
oneself sometimes a
person can be so hard on
himself and hold himself to
expectations that he could never
meet and blame himself to the point
where he would drive hopelessness into
his
heart this is a great crime in Islam
that a person become weary or hopeless
of the mercy of Allah subhanahu wa
taala and actually this is very arrogant
if a person commits any sin and they
wish to repent and they view that their
sin is greater than Allah's Mercy or
greater than Allah's forgiveness or too
great for Allah to
forgive and this person has committed an
even greater sin with
such conception of Allah subhanahu wa
taala he would constantly encourage
people with the best of
etiquet and he preferred starting with
the right the right side whether it be
in washing or bathing whether it be in
combing his hair or putting on his shoes
and in everything if there was a
situation where he should start with one
side as opposed to the other he would
choose to start with the right
[Silence]
side
s
[Silence]
for
tells us here
that usually his left hand he would use
when it comes to doing things or
starting with things with regards to
cleaning rather than
beautifying so for instance he would use
his left hand to wash his private
parts and so forth as opposed to his
right likewise when he would go to sleep
he would sleep on his right
side and NOA we here adds that he would
sleep on his right side towards the and
this is this is not
authentic the correct opinion of the
scholars of Islam with regards to these
narrations that tell us that his
mattress was facing towards the these
are weak
narrations we don't have
anything
authentic and explicit stating that he
would face the in his
sleep
rather the most that there is is a
narration in which the Prophet sallallah
alai wasallam said the best of positions
to
sit are those sittings or those
positions in which the is faced and this
is meant for in in in Dua
Etc if a person wishes to just make Dua
they want to sit down to make Dua it is
okay for them to sit down and face
the however this is not necessarily for
sleeping
[Silence]
only
was
likewise this issue of the right side we
see this often brought up in
slaughtering a lot of times people when
they
slaughter they will take
the animal and lay it on its right side
side if it's an animal that is laid not
all animals are slaughtered laid down
however if it is an animal that is laid
a goat or sheep lay it on its right
side facing the and that this is the way
that we would Slaughter however there's
no authentic narrations mentioning this
way of
slaughtering and this is counter in if
most people are
right-handed and we are now demanding
from them if the animals AR on its right
side that the person Slaughter with his
left hand and this goes against what we
know of the Prophet sallallahu alai
[Silence]
wasallam
for
and now we continues describing to us
the prophet Sall
alam's presence his company what kind
of company did he provide and what kind
of company did he keep his company was
one of forbearance and patience and
truthfulness and
honor and Tranquility it was not a a
rowdy
he would not keep Rowdy company his
company would be very
tranquil voices would not be raised in
his
presence
nor would foul or vulgar things be
mentioned such as descriptions of women
and such and so and such things these
would not be the topics discussed in
the prophet Sall
's
company the people that he kept as his
company and as his close companions were
very close with one another very
affectionate towards one another in
piety and very
humble
and the prophet sallallah alai wasam
would
give great
regard to the Elder those who are older
than him or those who are old in general
and he would be very merciful to those
who are
[Silence]
young
Islam
[Silence]
for
likewise the prophet s
was
would give great respect to those who
are Elder a good example of this is
when Abu bakr's
father became
Muslim this was during the conquest
of
Mecca Abu Bakr brought his father to the
prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam so
that he would pledge allegiance and
become
Muslim and he was described as being
elderly and had a very white and thick
beard very Lush white beard that was
a a cloud was so
white and when he brought him brought
his father to the Prophet sallallah alai
wasam to accept
Islam he said to Abu Baker why didn't
you tell me I would have come to him
rather than you bring this elder
gentleman to
me likewise the prophet sallallah alai
wasam when he
would
encounter those who are young he would
show great mercy and he would show them
respect he would speak to children with
respect of course children and adults we
speak to them in different ways however
disrespecting children and thinking that
because they have no influence in the
world or money in the world
Etc we will only respect people when we
have a reason to respect
them child has a right has the right of
a Muslim amongst us child has the right
of a Muslim amongst us it is
impermissible to do anything to
children that will harm them
or cause them to be sad or upset or feel
slighted this is something that happens
often it's almost like
people see children
and they don't give them very much
respect they don't give them very much
attention and this incorrect it doesn't
mean that we treat children exactly as
we treat adults of course we speak to
them differently they are in different
levels
however feeling that children have no
particular
right this is incorrect a Muslim child
has right and children in general they
have rights exactly the same as their
adult counterparts from amongst the
[Silence]
Muslim likewise the description of his
company was
that him and his companions they would
give precedence and give a voice to
those who needed something anyone who
was in need
could come and access the prophet sallai
wasam and any resources that he or any
of his companions had were able to
allot those resources to this person who
is asking they would do so they would
not
hesitate and they would also take care
of those who are passing through the
those who are not from here those who
are not locals Travelers people who are
strangers in their land would find
themselves more at home than they would
in their own
[Silence]
homes
another another
Hallmark of the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam company and his
companions those who would be in his
presence is that
that they would be
constantly a source and a guide to that
which is good that which is wholesome in
anything and the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam encouraged this when he
said whoever leads to a good they will
receive the reward of the one who does
it right whoever leads to that which is
good or encourages that which is
good
[Silence]
tells us that the prophet sallallah
alam's description as well was that he
would constantly do things that would
strike Harmony amongst the hearts of his
companions and he would always give
esteem and respect to those who were the
notables of their people meaning the
tribes leaders the Chiefs Etc he would
give them their due respect you cannot
speak to a King as you speak to a
peasant there's a certain code of
conduct and he would observe this code
of
conduct and the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would usually not
remove the leadership when when Islam
would come into a tribe A Tribe would
accept Islam the leaders before Islam
would usually be the same leaders after
Islam they would continue to be
leaders
[Silence]
likewise he would be
constantly examining his companions
and looking after
them and he was never vult V nor was he
ever
illicit and he would
never he would
never
respond to evil with evil
s rather he would be in constant
pardoning and overlooking other people's
mistakes and
misdeeds and he never never Strike
struck a
servant nor a
woman nor did he ever strike anything
anything meaning of the things which
people usually strike a servant women
those children Etc things people that
or or
animals he s wasallam had never done
such a thing was never recorded that he
had done such a
thing the only time that he would strike
with his hand
sallam is in
[Silence]
battle
for
another of his descriptions
Sall is that any time he had a choice
between two things two ways to do
something two paths two choices he would
always choose that which is easier as
long as it wasn't
Haram if it was Haram or something that
would lead to Haram then he would be the
furthest of people away from that
[Silence]
Haram
was
[Silence]
s
subh this is enough for
tonight